initially when i was speaking out or or
you know taking a stand
i made this major mistake so i didn't
speak out for a long time but then i
started to realize it's necessary
somebody's got to stand up and say a few
things and i've been um i've been
speaking out for quite a while now
and making my place
in support of
of the good and
and the sane
and uh what kind of reaction did you get
well i i you know
many people uh are upset with me in the
hollywood group right and family too
but uh
no one really confronts me
because they don't have the answers
they they fear my knowledge
in a certain sense just like yourself
you got too much too many facts too much
information and you're too eloquent to
be argued with
and so people get to a certain like if
somebody says something to me and i say
well you want to talk about it come on
come on my camper we'll talk and we sit
down
and
say well do you know this do you know
this and then
and then about a minute in they say you
know john i really don't know too much
about this stuff and they leave but i
want to judge you anyway
[Laughter]
well
it's funny the the people who don't want
to know things you know and or people
who want to follow
they want to follow
because they uh obviously their careers
um are on their minds they think that
their careers are going to be hurt if
they
uh
if they know too much about uh
if they know too much against what
the current uh
flavor is you know
of uh
of thought but
it's it's too bad
i've seen the uh the schools being over
been overtaken in my life the t the
teachers
there are no great teachers it seems
anymore there are but
boy they're
they're few and far between the ones
that are able to stand up to what's
going on
and
in our colleges
unbelievable but of course
i know enough to know that this didn't
happen accidentally it just didn't
happen because a lot of people just got
dulled
it happened because there were forces
that wanted to
propagandize wanted to bring us around
wanted to attack america
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight